[Music]
no yo speaking of eating look at this
dana white eating this [ __ ]
this dana white this dana white link yo
this killed me
just the first line i don't know how
deep you want to go on this [ __ ]
but it killed me everybody it is [ __ ]
friday here at ufc headquarters
today though we're going out of the
office and we're going to a place right
down the street
called cream bear i cannot tell you how
badass cool and unique this place is
positive so
today like his shirt kryptodoc
and they're going to a place called
cream what
place is badass i don't remember
cranberry
okay keep playing i'm gonna be trying
the cotton candy burrito
and the waffle taco here we go ladies
and gentlemen [ __ ] it friday
stop it stop it you cannot make this
hard
yeah what up ladies and gentlemen it's
[ __ ] friday and i'm going to
i'm going to creamsicle berry wonderland
to eat the cotton candy dreamsicle
this is a cotton candy burrito you're
eating a [ __ ] you're eating a rainbow
like the most gentle thing
on earth just an array of colors man
play it i did captain crunch
and sprinkles [ __ ] sprinkles cream
some [ __ ] ice cream it all up like a
burrito
this [ __ ] looks like furry [ __ ]
my ice cream is starting to eat through
the cotton candy
he hates it it's [ __ ] disgusting
that is literally like eating a care
bears [ __ ] goddamn
that is [ __ ] badass i feel like i
just ate out
a [ __ ] my little pony
this seriously tastes like my little my
little my little bony
my little pony this tastes like my
little boner
i have a i have a my little bony right
now for this
this tastes like my little pony
what the [ __ ] can you say about this
that's actually gonna be cool
what is he what is this for why is he
doing
i don't know why is he doing this
like is he affiliated with this i don't
know
why did you ever do this it's [ __ ]
friday you know what friday means it's
treat day baby
oh my god man it's time to take a bite
out of the teletubby land
[Laughter]
this literally tastes like all the
teletubbies [ __ ] in my mouth
what is he gonna say let this play this
one
it is way better than you would expect
it to be way better than you
there you go the cotton candy burrito
now we're going to try the waffle taco
yeah start off with some graham crackers
chocolate and marshmallows
you add in rolled ice cream
put it into a waffle for a second it's
funny because if he's doing this as like
some sort of paid deal or if he's like
an investor in this restaurant
you'd think you'd come up with something
better than it's actually way better
than you'd think you would yeah i think
it is
yeah it's actually pretty good all right
let's move on to the next one
what the [ __ ] all right play it go
add chocolate syrup add whipped cream
okay
and add s'mores all right guys so this
is the s'mores
waffle taco they're cream berry and
cranberries how good the first one was
yeah the burrito was
excellent it's a very very uh oh i
believe you deny it very good ice cream
if you guys like cream berry here in las
vegas here goes
the the taco
having a hard time
this is excellent and i'm telling you
you're lying bro is this thinking about
dana white just doing progressively
weirder plugs
that he's like bought into
so i don't have a [ __ ] but i'll tell
you this kegels program
[Laughter]
dog this website cream berry i'm certain
there are stoners that have
made better food with like top ramen
and chili flakes yeah then this wild ass
[ __ ] right here
creme berry
i feel like i'm looking at like an eye
spy book or something yeah what the [ __ ]
does anyone
is that even still a thing you remember
those i spy i love that [ __ ]
where's waldo remember that
where's waldee's nuts in your mouth oh
sheesh
hey guys what's up i'm here at creme
berry
i kind of want to go there now cranberry
yeah that's gonna stop i want to try
i want to try cream berry
wow that's really funny um
oh that post no there's yeah that what
we just watched what are you doing
sorry i was just um looking up hook up
the gps
yeah no i was just trying to see how
fast i get uh cream berry up here
it's gonna be like a few days so well
damn well
ah thank you guys for joining us i have
to say that bit ate me up
which one cranberry yeah same [ __ ]
girl suck barney's dick you know
that's what suck barney's dick you know
uh i don't know man that seriously
tastes like dr seuss's [ __ ]
doctor's juice
if you ever want to know what it tastes
like to get nutted in by a
who by the grinch by the grinch
this tastes like giving christmas back
um
oh my god oh man this tastes like
monsters inc
it tastes like monsters pink yeah
this tastes like the the real monsters
inc
the stuff that's inside sully
this this tastes like a bite out of
sully's balls
oh man mike wazowski mike wazowski in my
mouth
that's for sure
i feel like i just [ __ ] bob the
builder's mom god damn
all right guys i just did six shots of
howler had whiskey let's head to
cranberry
we're heading to creambury i'm [ __ ] up
i'm blacked out right now i want that
i want that barney dick thing
hell
what's up everyone we're going to we're
going to cranberry for chocolate taco
tuesday
i'm taking eight shots of howlerhead
and i'm eating out minnie mouse's [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] blacked out i'm so [ __ ] up
right now
we just did two happy dads and eight
shots of howler head
and i want that choco taco oh my god
who's the the purple [ __ ] from
mcdonald's grimace
i feel like i just sucked off grimace
all the years my mom would let me get a
happy meal let me tell you i'm making up
for it right here
i say grimace mom's ass
i'll give grimace a happy meal if you
know what i'm saying
is what big bird's feet tastes like
jesus christ man
let's go to cranberry man i'm down dude
yeah
okay vegas was right down there yeah we
could just float down yeah
beam down get us some goddamn
this [ __ ] honestly looks kind of good
honestly i want to go there